good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I'm
going to endeavor to explain what the
heck sequestration is why it's so
important and why it's so bananas but
first we have to understand a few things
about what governments do so there are a
lot of government programs that are
super popular with people like for
instance here in the US we have
something called Medicare which offers
inexpensive health care to older people
now Medicare is actually more efficient
and cheaper per person than private
insurance but it is still very expensive
because don't take this personally old
people but you get sick a lot we also
have a very popular program that offers
health care to our poorest citizens
called Medicaid and between those two
that's 23% of the federal budget
another 22% of the budget goes to Social
Security a very popular program in which
old people get checks every month so
they can buy you know like food and
computers by the way I know that they're
buying computers because suddenly a lot
of old people are reading The Fault in
Our Stars and they keep emailing me and
the subject line is like in all capital
letters my granddaughter recommended
that I read your book because she thinks
that I'm about to die I thought it was
funny and sad good job and then there's
nothing in the body of the email so we
need Social Security because how else am
I gonna hear from my older readers right
so those three programs are 45% of the
federal budget and they're what's known
as mandatory spending programs there's
an additional 13% of our budget that is
also mandatory spending like salaries
for federal judges and stuff and then
the interest on our national debt is 6%
of our budget so in total that stuff is
64 percent of the federal budget here
the 36 percent is discretionary spending
which Congress allocates yearly or
sometimes over multiple years or
sometimes only in ninety-day cents if
they're feeling very cranky and
inefficient that's everything from my
Veterans Affairs to building highways to
NASA to science research to meat
inspectors but more than half of all
discretionary spending doesn't go to any
of that stuff because it goes to defense
one of the piece of background
information as previously noted the
United States has a long-term debt
problem but it does not have a
short-term debt problem like right now
the US can borrow money extremely
cheaply arguably like cheaper than three
and that's because we're very strong
economy we've never defaulted on our
debt there's no reason to think that we
will and our budget deficit the annual
difference between what we take in and
what we spend is shrinking pretty fast
and is probably not a concern at the
moment but there is a serious long-term
problem with our mandatory spending
programs the cost of Medicare and
Medicaid will double over the next
thirty years as the population ages and
health care costs continue to rise and
the cost of Social Security will go up
too so in the long term we either have
to decrease benefits or in
increase revenues or both or else our
budget deficit will spiral and our debt
will get more expensive and Greece so we
have a long-term problem which requires
a long-term solution and that brings us
to the sequester right so back in 2011
the u.s. nearly defaulted on its
sovereign debt not because we couldn't
afford to pay the debt but because
Congress was refusing to raise the debt
ceiling which is particularly hilarious
because the reason we were reaching the
debt ceiling is because of budgets that
Congress had passed there seems to be a
little bit of confusion about this but
one in the United States Congress sets
the tax rates and two in the United
States Congress sets the budget and so
if the budget and the tax rates lead to
a deficit that is Congress's fault
literally presidents may like drop by
Congress to try to argue for whatever
they believe in but presidents do not
set tax rates and they do not decide the
budget so eventually Congress passed the
Budget Control Act in which they raised
the debt ceiling in order to pay for the
budget that they themselves had created
and in this Budget Control Act Congress
created a so-called supercommittee that
would address the nation's long-term
fiscal problems with a grand bargain
that would keep our debt from spiraling
out of control and greasing and in order
to force the supercommittee to do its
job Congress enacted another ticking
time bomb because we don't have enough
of those that was originally proposed by
President Obama called sequestration if
they didn't come to an agreement there
would be automatic cuts of 1.2 trillion
dollars over 10 years half cuts to
defense and half cuts to other spending
but vitally very little cuts to the
mandatory spending programs that are the
center of the long-term fiscal problem
which is such an incredibly bad idea
that the assumption was they would find
a way to compromise but yet no think of
the doctor told you at a slow-growing
tumor in your fingernail and you're
responding by saying quick remove my
gallbladder right so the reason that
sequestration is so bananas is not
because of the cuts themselves it's
because they're indiscriminate every
project program and activity of the
United States federal government has to
be cut by the exact same percentages
except for those mandatory spending
programs that are mostly exempt so
basically everything the government
currently does it has to do about eight
percent less of that doesn't sound that
bad but because it's every project
program and activity it gets super
bananas for instance something sort of
like this happened in 1991 with a 5%
sequestration and federal employees were
literally instructed to scrape 5 percent
less
bird poop off buoys in Chesapeake Bay
because that is a project program or
activity of the federal government so
instead of making a choice about which
federal programs we can afford to get
rid of we're just going to scrape 8
percent less poop off of all of the
buoys that is bananas it's gonna cost
between half a million and two million
jobs and instead of getting rid of jobs
because they're outdated or unnecessary
it basically just throws a dart at a
dartboard and more importantly
sequestration doesn't just create
problems it also fails to solve problems
because it does absolutely nothing to
address the long-term fiscal problem in
the u.s. because mandatory spending on
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security is
going to continue to grow it pretty much
the exact same pace so essentially heck
Congress saw a long-term problem which
they responded to by creating a
short-term crisis which they then failed
to solve these days the conversation on
the news channels tends to be about
who's terrible idea this was with
congressional Republicans being like
this was President Obama's idea and
President Obama being like I'm sorry do
I create and pass legislation in this
country but Hank this whole business
about only discussing who's to blame
distracts from the larger issue which is
that the sequestration is a disaster
it's inefficient and bureaucratic and
everything that people don't like about
government and it does nothing to make
our economy healthier so to summarize
the sequester creates an unnecessary
catastrophe without addressing the
larger future catastrophe it is an
embarrassment frankly Hank it is more
embarrassing than our continued minting
of pennies and that's saying something
I'll see you on Friday